une rénovation à coups de marteaux
piqueurs et de pelleteuses bientôt les
notes de l'école de musique d'elancourt
s'imposeront dans le quartier 17 mar en
lieu et place de l'ancien centre
oecuménique
le nouveau bâtiment de 700 m² avec une
quinzaine de salles au total pourra
accueillir jusqu'à 500 élèves dans
l'école de musique qu'on va avoir deux
salles qui sont des sales nouvelle
question des salles d'éveil pour la
musique ou les tout petits vont pouvoir
au plus jeune âge commencer
l'apprentissage de la musique et ça
c'est important
et puis après vous avez des salles de
cours des salles dédiées des salles des
petites salles qui sont par exemple pour
le piano pour la salle de percussions
qui l'a va avoir un traitement très
particulier sur ce nouveau quartier 17
mar la musique s'exportera même à
l'extérieur avec des gammes gravé sur la
dalle le sol est désormais recouverte
d'un enrobé rouge pour plus de sécurité
et assurer la circulation des personnes
à mobilité réduite
les travaux débutés en janvier doivent
profiter à l'ensemble des acteurs de la
vie locale
l'humain est au coeur de l'ensemble de
nos projets avec de l'intergénérationnel
de l'associatif
du la culture la possibilité de pouvoir
les gens qui sont donc en situation pmr
de pouvoir circuler correctement et
créer atterrir tout ça une véritable vie
un dynamisme qui va relancer l'activité
commerciale de notre d'arles
la fin des travaux est prévue pour le
premier trimestre 2010 8 pour un coût
total estimé à près de 5 millions
d'euros 66 % à la charge de
l'agglomération et le tiers restant à
celle d'elancourt